SCP-682 Vs SCP-536.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile seems to ignore
the laws of physics most of the time, but
how will he fare when the Foundation uses
the SCP-536 chamber to manipulate the laws
of physics around it?
SCP-682’s containment tank was moved into
the 536 chamber.
The speed of light, fundamental charge, and
nuclear force were increased progressively
over time.
The chamber was utterly annihilated in seconds,
but even when the process was done, and 682
was reduced to 1% of its normal size, it was
still alive.
One of the researchers lost it from the frustration
and began turning all the dials to torture
the creature.
He was removed from the cross-testing room,
but was later forgiven for his indiscretions
- with his supervisor noting that he would
have done the same, seeing as at times, 682
seemed almost like it enjoyed the process.